I guess I start with what's written on
the subject I just sort of do do
research have there been newspaper
articles have there been other magazine
articles now one of the tricks with New
Yorker stories is you want to pick a
story that is familiar enough that
people will want to read about it but
not so familiar that they feel like they
know already know everything and they
don't want to read a whole long New
Yorker story so usually when I pick a
subject there's some stuff written about
it but not a ton and then when I feel
like I sort of know what the issues are
I kind of work around the edges of the
story first I'll often talk to say with
me it's often a law professor who's
familiar with the story who can sort of
outline what the what's at stake you
know what's interesting what's what's
what's the hot controversy about it and
then maybe I'll start to talk to more
peripheral peripheral players in the
story and only at the end or the at
least the end of the beginning will I
try to interview the protagonists
because I think in order to ask good
questions you have to know a lot about
the subject to start with so I'm a great
believer in not going to the main
characters first because I need to
educate myself about it so I can ask the
right questions and then it's often just
a matter of finding scenes you know I
often think of New Yorker stories in
terms of set pieces in terms of you know
watching something happen as a reader
and thus as a writer so how can I go and
see if I'm writing a profile see the
person you know interact give orders
give a speech perform be backstage just
sort of how can I dramatize the story
one thing that I
I always worry about I mean I is that I
am in the business usually of writing
stories that have issues at their core
you know is is Alberto Gonzalez doing
his job as as Attorney General
you know what are we gonna do about
Guantanamo the challenge is to take
those issues and turn them into stories
people want to read the the the I always
want a story to be a narrative they hear
so here's how it started and their
complications ensued and here's how it
ended that said so that you know it
takes you along with you that it can't
just be about an abstraction and and
that that's a tug I often feel so well
in in my reporting I'm always thinking
about how do I make this into a story
and how do I in the famous journalistic
instruction how do I show don't tell how
do I show things happening rather than
just to explain